[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
as we make way for andrew brandt the
mmqb
columnist former packers executive
right let's go one by one here andrew
let's start with deshawn watson
how tradable is he
hey dan i'm not your clickbait guy
everybody's rushing to the fantasy
football trades and going
it's going to be really hard he signed a
new contract as everyone knows
four months ago four short months ago he
committed the texans four years and when
you do these big contracts
we'll talk about carson wentz too
there's
consequences and consequences if somehow
you move on somehow you separate
early in the contract which of course
would be you know incredibly early in
the contract
best case best case for the texans
would be leaving behind 27 million
dollars of debt money for people who
don't understand
debt money is not cash the cash has been
paid dead money is cap
accounting that stays on your cap even
after the player leaves
27 million for a player that won't be
there
now of course you know you're getting
rid of your franchise player your best
player you've got to add quarterbacks
in place of him so it's gonna be a lot
more than 27 million
allocated to quarterback but how long's
the 27 million stay
that would stay this year okay that's
just this year so and then
next year you know it would be off the
books but
again what is what is value
for deshaun watson i've said from the
beginning dan
they got a new general manager if he
trades deshaun watson he's going to be
an old general manager
pretty quick but if i was the the owner
and you were my gm and i
ordered you to trade desean watson what
would you ask for
well i think you're talking about a
young player at the top of his game
that's only going to get better
i i don't even know what to ask for i
mean the
this is kind of the james harden kind of
trade where you
have multiple number one picks you need
players back you need to replace the
position
i don't know if there's ever been a
trade like this uh you know
when we talk quarterbacks don't make it
to this kind of market
well we normally trade up to get a pick
right in a draft
and and we're giving draft capital there
this is an established
franchise legitimate top seven six
five quarterback probably in the nfl
right now playing on a bad team
once carson wentz we're gonna talk about
him but to get him
just give you an idea they traded a
first
and a fourth for that year a first and a
second
for the upcoming year okay and that's a
player who'd never play it
and who was coming in on a rookie
contract which is cheap
relatively so just think about those
kind of things i mean jashon watson
would be
multiple times that and again i
do not think it's going to happen carson
wentz
what's the likelihood he gets traded and
what would you be asking for in return
yeah i don't think he's gonna get traded
again because now we're talking about
here's that dead money number again dan
it's 34 million best case
now if they pay him the 10 million
roster bonus before they trade him or
june 1 kind of thing then it's 44
million not 34 million of dead money
so i don't think it's going to happen
we've seen the change with peterson
you know basically they chose wentz over
peterson
you know they chose the guy they want to
fix and the reason they want to fix them
is because such a massive investment
they're not going to move on from that
you know and again people say his
talents progressed well we know he's
done it right two years ago he played
mvp quality football
so someone's going to fix him it's not
going to be doug peterson i think he
stays
well you are a buzzkill you're not click
bait you don't think
this is this is not the nba you know you
trade james harden
and you get picks and players and all
that but there's no long tail of
economics that's what people
need to understand i managed to cap for
10 years nfl
economics is so different but if you're
desean watson's agent
you know the math here like like how do
you trade how do you get your client out
of
houston you know if you really want to
get them out
you pay back a lot of millions of
dollars you know i mean people have
suggested that which i think
i don't if i'm an agent i'm not
suggesting that yeah
you know this guy signed four months ago
i don't know what changed people say
well he had to take it because the money
was so big well
you know jack prescott that market's not
going to go down i don't think deshawn
watson
had any downside to waiting to do a
contract
even if injured his market was going up
but it you know i i look at this with
lamar jackson
and baker mayfield yeah if you're the
team
like does does it make sense for
cleveland to sign baker mayfield
now and and the same with the ravens
with lamar jackson
you know i think that we're back to
wentz here i think the wence
and maybe jared goff are gonna give
teams a little pause there
you know those teams jumped in after
year three gave the massive extension
and you hear sean mcvay talk about jared
goff and we know what's going on with
wentz
you know you get the feeling that they
should have waited yeah
and maybe you mayfield and jackson maybe
they do wait you know andrew luck
they waited till the fifth year trubisky
of course
never done a deal after his rookie but
that's different i know
mahomes they rushed in after three years
but there there may be pause with those
quarterbacks you mentioned to not do a
deal right away after the three-year
minimum allotment
where you can renegotiate any chance
andrew luck comes out of retirement for
the colts
i don't think so i'm just throwing it
out there i just yeah i mean i
i think it's he's he's a different cat
you know and i think he's in a lot of
different things besides football that
guy's not coming back
okay can you guarantee that carson wentz
and duchaun watson will
not be traded you got to put something
up here andrew
yeah you guarantee something
yeah i'm going to guarantee you okay
what are you willing to put up
i say again what are you willing to put
up
i'll come back on your program and gain
the wrath of all the haters
saying brandt you were wrong i mean i
don't how about
how about a a liquid cheese bath
because you used to be with the packers
so yeah
would you do a liquid a shower of
cheese on the show wisconsin cheese
yeah you'll do it i wear that helmet
behind me you can wear the helmet
but you would do a a shower of cheese
would you do that
i will if if they're not on their teams
i will do that
i will do that dan okay fair enough and
i would like to offer up mclovin if they
do decide to trade one of those two
mclovin would then do a
shower of cheese so that's mine
that's my gift yeah yeah
we're both philly guys he doesn't want
to see uh we could do philly cheese
we could do philly somebody has to have
cheese poured on him in here
i mean this is you know this is quid pro
quo here with andrew
who was you know what i'll do the cheese
oh nice yeah i'll do the cheese if uh
either one of these guys is not traded
okay if one of them's traded then then
you're gonna be a true cheesehead and
you are as well yes i will
yes i will uh i know you're uh working
with uh sports illustrator you got a
podcast newsletter
uh what are you working on what are you
covering newsletter you can sign up go
to andrew
brant.com i'm doing that newsletter
talking a lot about uh
you know memories this week you see the
helmet we just talked about it i was
there
my last game brett favre's last game
aaron's last game as
a backup when we hosted the nfc
championship before
that was the coldest game ever of course
tom coughlin's face was fuchsia
as you remember and unfortunately we
lost in overtime to the giants who went
on to beat the patriots who were
undefeated so
it was quite a memory you know um and
now they're back there
obviously i like their chances i'm
biased but it's great to see them back
there with hosting a championship game
once again
what are the odds aaron rodgers ends his
career as a packer
i think you know when they drafted
jordan love it just seemed like now we
have a separation date which is sad
but it's not going to be anytime soon
dan as we know he's mvp
and he's going to play next year but
maybe
you know just like him maybe three years
just like him with brett
you know it's a three-year window where
they develop
love and see what happens but you know
he has played lights out he's at the
top of his game as you know always great
to talk to you
and uh i've never looked forward to a
trade as much as i've looked forward to
maybe one of these trades with dushan
watson and or carson wentz
there will be cheese
for one of us there will be blood there
will be cheese
thank you andrew great to talk to you
again always a pleasure dad that's
andrew brown mmqb columnist and uh
the business of sports podcast former uh
packer executive there